the interesting thing is Einstein
himself didn't think that these
uh objects we call the black holes could
exist but let me actually Linger on this
yeah that's incredibly interesting
there's a lot of interesting things here
first was the speed limit
how Wild is it to you if you put
yourself in the mind in the time of
Einstein before him to come up with a
speed limit of that there is a speed
limit that and that speed limit is the
speed of light how difficult of an idea
is that is it you know you said from a
mathematic
mathematical physics perspective
everything just kind of falls into place
but he wasn't
perhaps maybe initially had the luxury
to think mathematically he had to come
up with it intuitively yes so like what
how common intuitive is this notion to
you well is it still crazy no no so it's
a very funny thing in physics the best
discoveries
seem completely obvious in retrospect
yeah
even my own discoveries which of course
are far lesser than Einsteins but many
of my papers many of my collaborators
get all confused well try to understand
something we said we've got to solve
this problem we'll get all confused
finally we'll solve it we'll get it all
together
and um
then we'll
all of a sudden everything will fall
into place we'll explain it and then
we'll look back at our discussions for
the precedings of months and literally
be unable to reconstruct
how confused we were yeah and how we
could ever have thought of it any other
way
so not only can I not fathom
how confused
Einstein was
before he when you know when he started
thinking about the issues I can't even
reconstruct my own confusion from from
two weeks ago uh you know so the really
beautiful ideas that physics have this
very hard to get yourself back into the
mindset
of course Einstein was confused
about many many things
um
doesn't matter if you're a physicist
it's not how many things you got wrong
it's not the ratio of how many you got
wrong coming you got right it's the
number that you got right
so Einstein didn't believe black holes
existed even though he predicted them
and I went and I read that paper which
he wrote you know Einstein wrote down
his field equations and
1915 and short Shield solved them and
discovered the black hole solution uh
three or four months later in very early
1916.
and um 25 years later Einstein wrote a
paper so with 25 years to think about
what this solution means yeah wrote a
paper in which he said that black holes
didn't exist
and I I'm like whoa
you know if one of my students in my
general relativity course wrote this
you know I wouldn't pass them you get I
get to see mine oh you wouldn't pass
them okay all right get to see Midas
okay same thing with gravity waves he
didn't believe oh he didn't believe in
gravitational waves either he went back
and forth but he wrote a paper and I
think 34 saying that gravity waves
didn't exist because it people were very
confused about what a coordinate
transformation is and in fact this
confusion about what a coordinate
transformation
is has persisted
and we actually think
we were on the
edge of solving it
100 years later
a hundred years later what is coordinate
transformation as it was a hundred years
ago to today let's imagine I want to
draw a map with pictures of all the
states and the mountains and then I want
to draw the weather forecast what the
temperatures are going to be all over
the country
and I do that using one set of weather
stations
and I number the weather stations
and you have some other set of
weather stations
and you
do the same thing so the coordinates are
the locations of the weather stations
yeah they're how we describe where the
things are
at the end of the day
we should draw the same
map
that is coordinate invariance
and if we're telling somebody uh we're
going to tell somebody at a real
physical operation we want you to stay
as dry as possible on your drive from
here to California
um we should give them exactly the same
route
no matter which weather stations we use
or how we you know it's a very trivial
it's it's the labeling of points is an
artifact and not in the real physics
sure
so it turns out that that's
almost true
but but not quite there's some
subtleties to it
the statement that you should always
have the same give these the same kind
of trajectory the same kind of uh
instructions no matter the weather
station yeah yeah there's some very
delicate subtleties to that which
began to be noticed in the in the 50s
it's mostly true but when you have a
space time with edges
it gets very tricky how you label the
edges and space-time in terms of spacer
in terms of time in terms of everything
just basically either one okay space or
time that gets very tricky and Einstein
uh didn't
didn't didn't have it right and in fact
he had an earlier version of general
relativity
in 1914 which he was very excited about
um which was wrong
um gave it wasn't fully coordinate and
variant it was only partially coordinate
invariant
it was wrong
it gave the wrong answer for bending
light to the Sun
by a factor of two
there was an expedition
sent out to measure it during World War
One
they were captured
before they could measure it and that
came that came Einstein four more years
to clean it to clean his act act up by
which time he had gotten it right
it's a very it's a very tricky business
but once it's all laid out it seems
it's it's it's clear